house of trump teil 2 die rückkehr ins
weiße haus was wir hier sind ist
tatsächlich us show business man sagt ja
in den usa showbusiness politik vorgibt
also politik politics ist showbusiness
von politik ist showbusiness für
hässliche menschen ein sprichwort in
washington dc wie weit man das hier
anwenden will muss jeder für sich selber
entscheiden
aber was wir hier tatsächlich sind es
natürlich die ganz große inszenierung
der ganz große wahlkampf und die ganz
große show und kraft und
machtdemonstration des us präsidenten
herbert bauernebel eben aus washington
uns live zugeschaltet hat uns ein
bisschen den medialen blick darauf
gegeben dass natürlich
gesundheitsexperten besorgten und
journalisten empört ich würde nicht
darauf wetten dass das bei und das
werden wir dann am wahltag in der
mehrheit der us-bevölkerung wirklich so
ankommt ich glaube die show die donald
trump da geliefert hat ist etwas was in
seiner wählerschaft bei den menschen die
im letztes mal gewählt haben fabelhaft
ankommt und ich würde auch sagen dass
dieser satz
habt keine angst lasst euer leben nicht
nominieren da sollten wir etwas
vorsichtig sein
wir neigen in deutschland ja auch dazu
sobald dort tun wird und jetzt
verharmloste ist ich glaube tatsächlich
der punkt nach sieben acht monaten in
dieser pandemie zu sagen lasst es nicht
ständig euer leben dominieren das leben
muss irgendwie weitergehen die
wirtschaft muss weitergehen wir müssen
weiterarbeiten geld verdient das ist ein
ganz ganz wichtiger punkt und den würde
ich nicht so abtun nach dem motto donald
trump war harmlos das schon wieder
sondern eher nutzt sozusagen die eigene
erkrankung und die eigene rückkehr und
diese erkrankung ist ja noch lange nicht
vorbei um eine politisch ganz ganz
wichtige botschaft zu senden und nicht
ich würde sagen nicht zu verharmlosen
sondern vielleicht die prioritäten für
diesen wahlkampf ein wenig in die
richtung in die richtung optimismus zu
verschieben und ich würde darauf tippen
dass diese inszenierung die wir da
gesehen haben bei sehr vielen menschen
den usa die wir uns in deutschland hier
gar nicht vorstellen können fabelhaft
ankommen wird
du sagst es ja selber wahrscheinlich bei
den leuten die ihn sowieso gewählt
hätten bei 1 die jetzt noch zu diesen
wechselwählern gehört hätten wie kommt
es daher das ist ganz das ist in den usa
ein bedarf eine sache bei den usa nie
vergessen es gibt nicht wie bei uns eine
bundesweite wahl sondern deswegen die
staaten und aus den staaten kommen die
wahlmänner männer und die will den
us-präsidenten vollkommen anderes volk
anderes prinzip und jetzt gibt es ja
verschiedene gruppen von
unentschlossenen und es gibt zum
beispiel die menschen die bei der
letzten wahl donald trump gewählt haben
wenn er die mobilisiert hatte eine gute
chance wiedergewählt zu werden
die jetzt vielleicht in den letzten
wochen monaten zweifel gehabt haben
haben ihren job verloren
donald trump hat teilweise ist wirklich
skurril aufgetreten
in dieser krise mit dem vorschlag
desinfektionsmittel zu trinken und so
weiter und so fort da kann man sich
durchaus vorstellen dass menschen
zweifel bekommen haben ich glaube dass
ganz viele von diesen menschen durch
diese show zu donald trump in gewisser
weise zurückfinden werden und sagen weil
wir lassen das nicht damit enden dass
der mann den wir gewählt haben
im krankenhaus ist und jetzt von joe
biden geschlagen wird ich glaube das was
wir da gerade sehen wird in dieser show
business welt vereinigte staaten seine
wähler auch die die vielleicht abwandern
wollten massiv zurück mobilisieren zudem
wegen jetzt dass ihnen dann auch im
tiefflug das sind ja wirklich bilder das
könnte in jedem hollywood vergleich
alleine einer wie gesagt haus auf trump
nächste folge die rückkehr ins weiße
haus was wir da gerade an den
bildschirmen unseren zuschauern zeigen
er hat eine spezielle flugroute gewählt
von walter reed ins weiße haus die in
diesen anflug auf das weiße haus bei
sonnenuntergang mit dieser kulisse
ermöglicht hat und eine sache ist ja
interessant alle medien in den usa die
donald trump nicht zu mögen sagen oder
ist ja schrecklich was er da macht die
selbstentzündung aber sie zeigen es
natürlich alle
das bild ist allgegenwärtig und absolut
übermächtig in einer art und weise wie
wir das noch nie erlebt um und alle
anderen themen sind ja auch weg die
story ist donald trump und mal gucken ob
das so bleibt aber im moment ist die
story nach drei tagen im krankenhaus
kehrt der präsident ins weisse haus
zurück aber man findet natürlich immer
was negatives wenn man danach sucht
deswegen gibt es jetzt auch videos die
zeigen sollen wie donald stand
tatsächlich dann aber probleme hat beim
atmen leer tief und sehr schwer atmet
und die frage ist sind das nicht dort
anzeichen dafür dass er sich gesunder
gibt als er eigentlich ist wir sehen es
jetzt gleich sobald er die maske
natürlich abreißt von sich selber weil
donald trump war keine masken dass kein
druck da muss man einmal nämlich da
müssen wir aufpassen dass wir unseren
zuschauern da auch nicht diesen
einseitigen blick auf den eltern
vermitteln an der stelle hätte jeder
deutsche politiker seine maske auch
abgenommen
an der stelle an der man nicht um
von menschen wohl niemand anders herum
ist darf er die maske abnehmen
es gibt ganz viele punkte zum beispiel
als er seine rede auch mit maske als
hätte man ja das nicht so national
zeitung aber solange er niemanden
gefährdet muss er nicht irrational
handeln der us-präsident ist nur weil
ihn viele mögen nicht dazu verpflichtet
irrational zu handeln um menschen die
ihn nicht mögen keine angriffsfläche zu
bieten da muss man ganz ganz vorsichtig
sein und differenzieren was man auf den
bildern aber sieht ist dass er schon
bisher außer atem ist und etwas keuchend
spricht und die bilder die er dann
geliefert hat ja die erinnern uns
deutlich mehr an monarchin als eine
demokratie muss man sagen dass winken
auf dem auf dem balkon wo sich der
herrscher zeigt ist etwas was wir aus
demokratien jetzt eigentlich weniger
kennen aber auch dass die usa us
wahlkampf noch mehr als der super bowl
noch mehr als hollywood the greatest
show on earth
der wahlkampf ist es da jetzt deine
einschätzung wir sehen jetzt hier gerade
was du meinst er lässt sich da oben
etwas feiern aber im endeffekt du denkst
das bringt dem sogar jetzt noch positiv
pluspunkte auf den letzten metern ist es
nur noch einen monat nicht mal das ist
nicht mal mehr einen monat wir sind in
der wir sind quasi am vorabend
symbolisch gesprochen der der us-wahl
was man auf jeden fall sagen kann ist
dass die beiden jetzt erstmal derzeit in
der berichterstattung nicht mehr
vorkommt und mediale aufmerksamkeit
berichterstattung präsenz auf
titelseiten auf websites im fernsehen in
der primetime ist natürlich ein ganz
wichtiges element im wahlkampf menschen
müssen sich erst einmal erinnern dass es
jemanden gibt dass er irgendwie da ist
um ihn dann zu wählen und das ist ein
ganz entscheidendes element was man aus
meiner sicht hier nicht unterschätzen
sollte man kann sagen es ist nicht
prognostizierbar wie diese wahl ausgehen
wird ich würde aber sagen dass die
menschen die dort schon einmal gewählt
haben
nach den bildern die wir derzeit erleben
ihn auch ein zweites mal wählen werden
ich glaube das was wir da gerade ersehen
ist für donald trump 1 1 1 mobile sator
ja eine 1 1 zurück ins gedächtnis rufen
wäre es unser commander-in-chief ich
glaube das wird sich auf das publikum
was träumt schon einmal gewählt hat
positiv auswirken und dann ist die frage
was wird joe biden dem entgegensetzen es
kommt möglicherweise noch eine debatte
oder zwei debatten womit mobilisiert der
beiden
aber dass die beiden relativ wenig
mittel hat dieses experiment diese
aufregung auszulösen ich glaube da sind
wir uns alle einig er kann ihm dem
vernunft entgegenstellen und
besonnenheit und eine andere tonalität
aber wer amerika ein bisschen kennt und
der sagt das sehen muss dass donald
trump schon einmal diese wahl gewonnen
hat was ja auch ausgeschlossen schien
vor vier jahren
der sieht ja und weiß ja dass amerika
und auch das politische amerika ein
showbusiness betrieb ist und wie gesagt
ich habe es an dieser stelle vor ein
paar tagen schon mal gesagt wenn uns das
jemand vor sechs sieben monaten als
realität prophezeit hätte hätten wir
alle gesagt das würde nicht mal netflix
als drehbuch annehmen und jetzt erleben
wir es jeden tag für unseren staunenden
augen mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren